find me right and I got nowhere to be I
was just the [ __ ] workaholics it up
in again what there's Rob Babin here is
all bent out of shape he just said today
is rough to be very frank with you
vaynernation
I don't give a [ __ ] he ain't gotta be up
in the office
you have zapped it will be through
corporation talked about ownership and
leverage 1800 sexes out there beverage
period like immediately said yesterday
was [ __ ] epic because I was able to
do a ton of uh Instagram stories and
snapchat stories for you guys because I
was traveling in and out to Kansas City
not so much today
Grindr in the office but should be good
hope you have a great day
hello my friend did you see you great to
see you again give me two seconds
Facebook's the one place that you can
break out because you can speak English
more than good enough okay more than
going on it you just do the same thing
okay it's a single it's one day at a
time it's one day at a time it's making
a video in English to your Facebook fan
page and saying tag one I think you
should make your community how many fans
on Facebook yeah right now I have my
personal profile is full obviously yeah
but the fan page twenty thousand you
came in Slovenian Croatian but I have
English for five thousand we might start
heavily I got it I get don't worry I
mean there's accounts where I have
nothing like it
never worried where you have small basis
what I would say is on the Instagram and
the Americans speak on the on the the
Croatian Slovenian kind of speaking
Facebook pages I would make English
content okay I have a look and original
content and say and make them part of it
okay if I told you one piece of advice
tonight in your hotel room you say my
friends today I want to start the
process of breaking into the American
market okay and you can do me a huge
favor
which is please tag one or two American
or English speaking friends and that
will start the process okay and the next
day you make a piece of content that's
motivational or instructional or
strategic okay
it's the place of virality man here's
who's crucial I was I'll tell you ready
I'll tell you what the I'll tell you in
two seconds a writer okay somebody who
writes yeah a video person like the rock
and that maybe two people are one people
d rock and taught my people Tyler they
can film and edit some people can only
do one but there's enough young kids who
can do both so I would have one person I
would try to make it one person click
keeps across town three
a designer pictures a designer somebody
who makes pictures and quotes and images
the next one is audio you need an audio
technician so that you can do podcast
it's gonna be very important so that's
four and now number five up here at the
top yes PM project manager or architect
we'll talk more I'll help you okay thank
you very very pile pleasure to me
dissipation yeah of course
[Music]
is it a how are you 3d on really well
how are you guys I'm the best listen I'm
sorry by the way you know why I say it I
take no credit
what the [ __ ] did I do what's going on
is we're establishing that I'm the
greatest and then it's dangerous for us
to make ideas based off of me because
I'm so [ __ ] good that I take no
credit for I give all the credit that
huh
tomorrow and Sasha when I say I'm the
best [ __ ] were watching this
vlog licen the best at them compliments
my mom and dad I do [ __ ] so I mean first
of all it's so much better to make
decisions in your life for yourself and
have other people do it I'm going
nowhere I'm here for you forever not
gonna lose your number like I'm not mad
you shouldn't be leaving on these issues
and I can't let that happen
nobody will believe or care about you
more than me at a power position it's
impossible
[Music]
it's such a pleasure to meet you thank
you you're huge inspiration to me thank
you for just graduated college I found
it about 15 different companies my first
one what's your name's Michael I think
you'll be hopefully seeing a lot of me I
know you're busy I don't want to get in
between but 15 minutes for coffee at
some point or
than just an email to see you send me an
email to Gary at vaynermedia failure to
do that came in and also in the Bolivia
in the title I'll go to the skateboard
I'll remember we'll figure something out
what there's rough
babban here is uh all bent out of shape
he just said today is rough to be very
frank with you vaynernation I don't give
a [ __ ] if Tyler or you think today was
rough because I had 17 meetings that he
couldn't be a part of because I'm
actually running a [ __ ] business here
I'm not from some [ __ ] teenage beanie
Bopper trying to do a vlog or some
[ __ ] influencer doing a [ __ ] blob
or some [ __ ] family that's open for
some free detergent because of their
[ __ ] blog I'm [ __ ] working here
Tyler
so sorry that your [ __ ] video blog is
rough but let me tell you what's not
rough what's not rough is we're living
through the great era of ground shift in
marketing and business everybody in this
[ __ ] amazing town of New York City
which is let me just tell you everybody
who's not here [ __ ] vibrant at Tenet
p.m. right now because 98 percent of
your cities are [ __ ] sleeping
everybody here is [ __ ] their [ __ ]
collective pants because the ground is
shifting everything that our
grandparents and parents grew up with
everything that we knew tried-and-true
the stable pillars of media commerce
influence persuasion the way we make
decisions the things we buy and how what
is cool and what is not is unfuckin
called the world is on call and you know
what that means
hustlers the opportunity is obnoxious so
whether you're focusing on vlogs or
influencers or how to hack Instagram
stories or how to create alexa voice
skills or how to create your own podcast
because you see i'm [ __ ] full
committed till if you are not following
my podcast [ __ ] pissed
the way I call today the the sum up of
all my meetings today none of which you
just watched is that the earth is moving
there's instabilities in the foundation
of how it was which makes an innovator
like me really [ __ ] happy
and what suffocates all you B players
because you like it you like it nice
slow and stable let me be very clear
with this ending rant that game is over
and the people that are gonna win over
the next five to seven years are gonna
be very comfortable and controlled
[ __ ] chaos so you better get your
speed up you better work harder you
better work smarter you better try
things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do you better [ __ ]
move
[Music]